Remember an ACL is per object or
per resource?
It tells us user ID, what access that
user has, and the next user ID and
what access that user has, and
some number of entries like that.
And by the way, access control entries,
or ACEs is what they're called.
So where should ACL for
an object be stored?
So first of all this has to be stored
in the trusted part of the system.
It has to be stored in the operating
system of the trusted computing
base because it actually
determines who can access
a resource that needs to be protected.
If it's not in the trusted part,
then some untrusted code or application
potentially can change it but
where exactly does it go in that system.
So we know that it is a list of
these access control entries.
And this is for
a given object or a resource.
Such a list exists.
And ACL exists for each resource.
So we have the resource R
is going to have an ACL R.
One natural place for
us to store this ACL,
is where other information about
the resource or the object is stored.
So the other information typically
what we call is meta-data about
that resource.
So if the resource was a file for
example meta-data might
say the size of the file,
where on disk it may be stored,
who the owner is, and things like that.
We can store the ACL along with
that other meta-data that you have.
So we're going to do an example for
the Linux system,
Unix systems, how file system
access control is implemented.
And we're going to see that ACL
information actually gets stored
same place where meta-data about a file
is stored in the operating system.
We said meta-data has bunch of other
information where ACL is going to
be stored as well, so then the question
is, how do you use this information?
So remember for an object resource
if somebody's going to use it,
the object or
resource has to be activated.
So it's ready for use.
The meta-data has to be acquired,
something has to be set up
in the operating system.
And once that is done,
then the request is going to come.
So at that time we have
to perform a check,
access control check to decide if
the request should be granted.
So how do we perform that
access control check?
Let's say it's coming from Alice.
The request source is,
we know is Alice's UID, and
the request is for file foo.
We're going to go to the meta-data for
file foo,
where we're also going to find ACL for
file foo.
And once we have that ACL, we basically
have to traverse it, looking for
an access control entry for Alice.
And then see if the access rights
in that ACE grant permission
to this object to Alice in the manners
of what kind of request is being made.
So for example, it's read of a file,
and does the read access write exist
in the ACL or the ACE that we
have in the ACL for user Alice.
So traversal basically says when a
request comes from a given user, we have
to go down the list to see if an ACE
exists for the source of the request.
And if it does,
does it include permissions consistent
with the nature of the request.
And if that's the case,
then we can go on to access.
If you can't find such an ACE or
the access right doesn't exist,
so there is an access ACE
that says you can read but
the request is for write,
then also we are going to deny it.
So now you understand
how ACLs can be used.